are women burst today have you noticed
that women are like substantially worse
now than what you guys
um would you say they're study or now
more
um
I'm just curious because a lot of times
I I think sometimes Generations
but or I wanted to know if they're
actually would you say social media
I would say social media made
say social media
more attitude more entitlement
and more access to men
so would you say in your 20s dating was
easier
[Music]
um
yeah it was definitely easier because
also because it was more face-to-face
social like you just said people are
actually interact with people
walked on and it's not within
interaction
uh you know I was speaking today and
it's like okay if I don't know what
you're like
we can
all that energy we can feel each other
and these people are looking on phones
right now
so a lot of time when people meet up
face to face in person yeah but that's
why that's why you should still be
face to face yeah
it's like I should be different
and the reason is
[Music]
I remember I remember
who are on social media
the Dynamics the Dynamics were always
the same women always wanted the best
guy you know at school if you weren't
the guy who
was she was always the hierarchy has
always been
so I don't think it was magically here
for Instagram
play I think what has changed and this
is where
point
of the dating apps and social media we
have opened and blown open
opportunities for women soon to be
approached by
bike
so whereas before you know
in the south of England
[Music]
theoretically he
uh
exactly so do you guys think
social media is making
better easier for you personally but but
just just connect
Ed I suppose
ever like oh you could [ __ ] Joe
needs
that was never easy but
um I think that the increased
competition
for sure
um
[Music]
uh showcase your personality in real
life
so for me personally it hasn't made a
huge difference but I'm operating in a
different way because I've traveled
really on the
on the outside
what was the question I was just curious
for you personally because you have a
bit of a platform
if social media has made it harder or
easier for you personally
for me
I've been I've always been a social
person
and it's just me
so I've always loved to interact with
people socially
as it made it easier yeah of course
that's because
I made you more cautious
so it's like
I don't know you I'm interacting with
you but
you
guys
and I think social media is also
contribute to
being more
because this little it is actually a
force reality yeah
you know so obviously I'm a woman right
but I'm married to a man who's
listening that same question actually
curious was it better was it you just
basically told me he was like no there's
always been City girls
outfits yeah well I'm just thinking like
the girls that they complain about that
are older and acting like city girls
like before social media they were still
there
oh
I just I think I'm a Christian I feel
bad
told me there's been hoes in the 80s
exposure to like real female nature
whereas like you had to be the guy who
understood women
well
it is
[Music]
good looking somebody
but I got a friend of
mine's a guy
he doesn't meet nobody to
cook right a good idea which is a friend
of mine and she's not even particular
with looking at all she got three
thousand heat per month
let's look
right
and they don't want to meet their life
[Music]
when I interact with people I need to
understand
this is somebody communicates for real
or is doing
all right
um
so I have a more opportunity
[Music]
he got some really good shots
you know
somebody
okay you're not representing what they
see on the picture as a very much
right so even if
there's no political the
Where You Are
what are you gonna make you
[Music]
your parents
you know yeah yeah of course
there
is
nothing like if you
were a great looking
1992
. as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible